Điếu thường lại ô tô từ khu vực bẩy gên vào chút tâm thành phố Hội Chí Minh Hạc,
từ ngày 18, bạn sẽ phải trọng một tuyến đường khác thay cho các mạc thần tâm.
Muyến nhân là khoảng 3,5 kí lúc mết đường từ ngả từ bẩy gên đến vòng xa dân chủ sẽ cấm ô tô trạc
để thị cơm đăng gầm Mê Chô số 2.
Nếu xa phát từ khu vực bẩy gên, bạn có thể tham khảo hai lộ trình sau.
Lộ trăm một, đi đường đi từng kẹt, rồi giải trái vào đường 18, đến vòng xa dân chủ,
rồi tiếp tục đi theo mạc thần tâm để vào chút tâm thành phố.
Với lộ trình này, bạn cũng có thể đi lý thường kẹt,
sẽ trái bắc hai đến thành thái khoảng 2,
tổ hiện thành xưa vạn hành sau đó sẽ được 18,5.
Lộ trình 2, đi trường trình khoảng văn thu,
lê bình, khoảng xa, dạc bụng bình và huyện thành quan,
vóa thị sấu đến vòng xa dân chủ.
Từ đây tiếp tục đi kích mạc thần tâm vào chút tâm.
Lưu ý, các tiền trên chỉ mạng bính tham khảo,
bởi mặt độ phương tiện có thể thay đổi lý tục.
Chứ lực lại vẫn khóa đặc biến thường,
diên xe biết được phép trải hai chều.
Giài gần 5 kí lồ mẹ,
kích mạc tham là một trong những trục sạo thông chính
kết nối chút tâm thành phố hội trị mình với khu bực biệt tây bắc.
Và cũng nằm trên hành lăng mê cho số 2,
đến thành tham lường.
Công chính mê cho dự kiến hoàn thành năm 2018.